قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان ثلاثه
مسلحين فلسطينيين قتلوا واصيب اسرائيليان
في عمليه تبادل لاطلاق النار
بمستوطنة
نعم مسي لا تزال قوات الاحتلال حتى هذه
اللحظه تجري عمليات بحث وتمشيط واسعه في
اكثر من منطقه في الخليل يظهر هنا في هذه
الصوره كما تشاهدون هذه القنابل المضيئه
التي تستخدمها قوات الاحتلال في عمليات
البحث والتمشيط المستمره في المنطقه
القريبه من مستوطنه ادوه غرب الخليل وهي
المنطقه التي وقعت فيها العمليه قبل حوالي
ساعتين من الان وا ايضا في سماء بلده تفوح
غرب الخليل منطقه عين فرعا وكل هذه
المناطق القريبه من مستوطنه ادوره هذه كما
تشاهدون قنابل مضيئه تستخدمها قوات
الاحتلال في عمليات بحث وتمشيط مستمره
ومتواصله بعد ان دفعت بتعزيزات كبيره الى
موقع اطلاق النار عند مستوطنه ادوه غرب
الخليل الذي جرى هو قيام ثلاثه مسلحين
فلسطينيين ب التسلل الى هذه المستوطنه
وقام احدهم باطلاق النار تجاه حارس كان
متواجد عند مدخل المستوطنه فيما تمكن
اثنان اخران من الوصول الى داخل المستوطنه
وجرى عمليات اشتباك لكن قوات الاحتلال
اعلنت انها يعني قتلتهم الثلاث وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن ثلاثه شهداء هويتهم لم تعرف
حتى هذه اللحظه السي نحن نتحدث عن يعني
عمليه مستمره ومتواصله عمليات بحث وتمشيط
كما يظهر في هذه الصوره وحتى اللحظه لم
يعلن عن هويته عن اسماء الشهداء الثلاثه
ولا حتى عن مناطق سكنهم قوات الاحتلال
اغلقت كافه مداخل مدينه الخليل حتى انها
في بعض المناطق قامت بلحم البوابات
الحديديه بشكل نهائي واغلاق تام عند منطقه
اذنا تحديدا ومدخل الخليل الشمالي ايضا
مغلق وجرت العاده ان تقوم قوات الاحتلال
بعد كل عمليه اطلاق نار او كل عمل مقاوم
في الخليل ان تغلق كافه مداخل المدينه وان
تجري طوقا امنيا شاملا متوقع ان تشهد هذه
الليله اقتحامات لمناطق متفرقه في الخليل
لا سما على الاقل حتى يتم معرفه هويه
الشهداء الثلاثه الذين استشهدوا كما اعلنت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه طبعا عن مقتلهم كما
قلنا نحن نتحدث ايضا عن استهداف مستمر
ومتواصل للخليل اغلاق ل بلدات ومدن
ومخيمات في الخليل ل تزال مغلقه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر حتى هذه اللحظه كما
تحدثنا ايضا في رساله سابقه عن ان العدد
الاكبر من المعتقلين الذين تعتقلهم قوات
الاحتلال ما بعد السابع من اكتوبر هم من
مدينه الخليل غالبيه هؤلاء يحولوا
للاعتقال الاداري طبعا نحن نسمع في هذه
اللحظات ايضا في سماء المنطقه سوات
الطيرات والطيارات الزنانه التي لم تغادر
المنطقه وهي تشارك في عمليات البحث
والتمشيط المستمره وال المتواصله هذه هي
صوره المشهد حتى اللحظه في الخليل لكن كما
ذكرنا متوقع عن تشهد الساعات القادمه ربما
مزيد من التطورات هنا في الخليل جنوب
الضفه الغربيه y